President Trump wins big on his
immigration deal with Mexico of course
the mainstream media won't give him any
credit for that so we will examine what
is really in the deal then deadbeat
parents want the government to feed
their kids for them
pervert parents pimp their kid out to
drag bars and the gay stop o su
masterpiece cake shop owner Jack
Phillips for a third time then another
social media platform bans conservatives
all that more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a lot to get to today because I
noticed almost nobody is covering this
Trump Mexico deal fairly there and I
notice almost no one is actually reading
from the deal so we'll get to that first
and then we've got to get to some really
inspiring stories from ten-year-old
Americans and some really profoundly
disturbing stories from ten-year-old
Americans all that but first let me help
you big token is a new app that lets you
share your data about yourself your
interests and habits and then get paid
for it because right now you're already
sharing all of your information all of
your information is going out to big
tech companies that hate you and they
all make money off of it you should make
some money too that's where big token
comes in here is how it works first you
download the app you sign up for a free
big token account I just did this you
complete the actions you earn points
it's that simple I thought this was
going to be more complicated it's not
actions include answering surveys
checking into locations just where you
are already connecting your social media
accounts and more then you get a bunch
of points you redeem those points for
rewards like cash or gift cards or if
you're a nice guy
you can donate those earnings to charity
you can choose which data you share with
big token then you get paid for it it's
like you're just doing what you are
already doing - a lot of big tech
companies except now you get paid you
can also get more points for referring
friends and family your data are always
secured with big token based on the data
you choose to share you will be placed
into specific ad groups brands will then
buy access to those ad groups and you
will get more personalized advertising
the best part is I just have to remind
you you will get paid for it if you want
to start earning money for your data go
to the App Store or Google Play search
for big token bi GT o ke n that's one
word download the app and sign up make
sure though and this is the most
important part you use my referral code
NOLs KO wles so that i get the credit
and my show doesn't go off the air again
you have to search big token in the App
Store or Google Play
download the app use my referral code
Knolls Kanter wles to sign up claim your
data and get paid talk about good deals
president Trump just secured a very good
deal with Mexico over immigration
walking back the threat of tariffs this
has been in the news for three weeks
non-stop the Trump trade war it's going
to destroy the whole world everything's
going to hell in a handbasket so then on
Friday President Trump secures the deal
with Mexico I go to try to figure out
the specifics of this deal
none of the mainstream media articles
actually cover the specifics I could not
find the text of this deal anywhere
eventually I just had to go to the White
House website to read the joint
statement from the United States and
Mexico what were the headlines over this
deal Washington Post the dubious art of
Trump's deal with Mexico
you see it's dubious USA Today Donald
Trump claims there's more to migrant
deal with Mexico than he announced but
offers no specifics what did what did he
announce I don't you haven't told me
CNN Trump fights back against skeptics
of his New Mexico deal against the
skeptics who are the skeptics CNN that's
who but that's the story not that
President Trump secures a good deal not
what is in the actual deal no no it's
fighting back against the skeptics by
which they mean of course CNN what
actually happened President Trump has
been threatening tariffs on Mexico if
Mexico does not help us to stop illegal
immigration into the United States got
to remember if you're gonna cross the
southern border into America you've got
to cross into Mexico first the vast
majority of these illegal aliens coming
into America are not Mexicans they come
from Guatemala El Salvador Honduras
other other places in Central and South
America then they cross into Mexico then
they come to America so President Trump
said listen Mexico you've got to put
some security along your southern border
and stop this before it becomes a
problem for us
Mexico hasn't done it because it's
mostly a failed state and because Mexico
has a huge economic incentive to
continue to allow illegal immigration
when these illegal aliens are pouring
through Mexico's southern border on
their way into America this brings a lot
of money to Mexico's economy on most of
that money is going to the cartels but
then that those cartels are spending all
that money within Mexico in Mexico's
economy and we're talking about over a
billion dollars at least so Mexico has
no norm
economic incentive to stop illegal
immigration and they have a lot of
incentives to keep it going so president
Trump threatens tariffs and everyone
said this wasn't gonna work
oh no the tariffs are gonna hurt the
American economy nobody takes Trump
seriously he doesn't really mean it well
president Trump has slapped tariffs on
our foes and on our allies and so he
said listen I'm not joking about this I
will do it and it goes down to the final
hour when they could be negotiating this
deal and what happens
Mexico agrees to beef up its immigration
protection that's what happened we were
told the tariffs are going to destroy
the economy he's not really gonna get
any concessions because of the tariffs
the tariffs aren't even gonna work and
all of those critics were proven totally
wrong and president Trump's strategy
totally worked
I don't know how else to say it I guess
it could have been a little bit better
we'll get into how in a second but this
is a major win I mean this is a
basically unqualified win for Trump and
an unqualified loss for his critics who
said that tariffs weren't going to work
what is in the agreement the joint
statement from the US and Mexico reads
Mexico will take unprecedented steps to
increase enforcement to curb irregular
migration to include the deployment of
its National Guard throughout Mexico
giving priority to its southern border
Mexico is also taking decisive action to
dismantle human smuggling and
trafficking organizations as well as
their illicit financial and
transportation networks additionally the
United States and Mexico commit to
strengthen bilateral cooperation
including information sharing and
coordinated actions to better protect
and secure our common border now this
last part is subject to some scrutiny
from the mainstream media because
President Trump said as part of this
deal Mexico is going to buy a whole lot
of new American products and so that's
going to help with our trade deficit now
there's not a lot of evidence that
they're gonna buy more products the
Mexican ambassador is saying that
nothing has been ironed out specifically
so what President Trump is referring to
is this line here about greater co-op
raishin the implication being Mexico's
gonna buy some more US goods
who knows that part I don't think really
matters at all I mean I guess it would
be nice if Mexico bought more more goods
but that's not really what this deal is
about what this deal is about is dealing
with illegal immigration we have a lot
of trading partners they can buy more
American goods the the what we need
Mexico for is to stop the flow of
illegal aliens which now are three three
thousand per per day in some cases I
mean a lot of people coming in to the
United States
what is Mexico going to do they've
already deployed 6,000 National Guard
troops to the southern border that is a
very tangible step in the right
direction so what is the what else does
the deal accomplish they right the
United States will immediately expand
the implementation of the existing
migrant protection protocols across its
entire southern border this means that
those crossing the u.s. southern border
to seek asylum will be rapidly returned
to Mexico where they may await the
adjudication of their asylum claims big
win what this means is that the people
who do get into Mexico and then they
come into the United States and they ask
for asylum we will not have to keep
those people in the United States we
will be able to send them back to Mexico
and Mexico will take them now when this
first began a few months ago when these
negotiations were taking place Mexico
limited the scope of holding the asylum
seekers so they said ah both keep some
asylum seekers but not all of them we're
gonna limit how many can come here now
they will accept an unlimited number of
asylum seekers and this is very
important because in in the United
States
if you come you seek asylum what we
generally do is we lose track of you and
then you just get into the United States
and then you're just here and you don't
show up for your adjudication hearings
and you don't ever need to show up in
court again because you're you've
already gained entrance into the United
States sometimes with more than one of
you sometimes with a whole family unit
keeping them on that other side of the
border is crucial to reducing the flow
of illegal aliens and this was a major
win this is also important because it
limits family units the people who are
coming seeking asylum specifically who
say they're seeking a
usually they're just economic migrants
but they say they're seeking asylum come
with a lot of people and it this creates
major political problems now you're not
allowed to split up the parents from
their children and hold the children
with HHS Health and Human Services and
hold the parents in cells you're also
not allowed to put the children in cells
I mean this is the reason why in 1997 we
decided that eventually I had to split
up the parents and the children anyway
so you're in a situation where you're
damned if you do and you're damned if
you don't if they get into the United
States and get to stay there while they
seek asylum now they get to go back to
Mexico the deal could be slightly better
so what we what we would really like to
secure here is something called a safe
third country agreement a safe third
country agreement we have one of these
deals with with Canada which is that
when people are coming in from a third
country which ever country they arrive
at first if they come through Canada
they're going to Mexico or where if they
come to the United States and they're
going to Canada that the country they
arrive at first is the country where
they have to seek asylum they can't just
keep going through to get to the better
country and this gets to the whole
argument of asylum what the left is
saying in this illegal immigration
dispute is it's these desperate people
who are just seeking a better life and
avoiding threat of death in their own
countries in Guatemala let's say and
what the right is saying is no they're
not they're coming for economic
opportunity in the United States the way
you know the the right is correct here
is if they were just fleeing the threat
of immediate violence in their home
countries they wouldn't walk through 20
different countries on their way to the
United States they wouldn't march from
South America all the way up to the US
they could seek asylum in any country
along the way but they're not seeking
asylum they're seeking economic
opportunity as the u.s. is a way better
place to live in than Mexico so what a
safe third country agreement would do is
say okay if you're gonna come and you're
gonna enter Mexico first then you're
getting asylum in Mexico and you you
can't seek asylum in the United States
you've got to seek asylum in Mexico
obviously Mexico doesn't want to do that
that would be slightly better but what
we've got is is quite good it could have
been a lot worse
- even the guys at national
review which is a never Trump
publication right it's been decidedly
antitrump they made him they're a huge
issue in 2016
against Trump so many of their editors
and writers have been opposed to Trump
even National Review said we've got two
candidate - Donald Trump on this point
and so if it's good enough for nr and
the anti-trump forces on the right it's
good enough for me
we'll get to the main takeaways here
then we'll move on to a very inspiring
story but first you should not have to
choose between overpriced designer
sunglasses and cheap shades that won't
last you through the summer I have had
both and now I have movement sunglasses
and movement sunglasses or the best
sunglasses you know movement I got my
movement watch on it's the watch I get
most compliments about movement totally
disrupted the watch industry now they
are doing it again with sunglasses these
are constructed with durable acetate and
lightweight materials for that perfect
reliable fit you don't need to choose
between style and function with movement
you get both and with free shipping and
returns policy you can try on as many as
you want right from your home I am a
sunglasses aficionado I'm from the east
coast from New York and of Italian
descent so I've been wearing sunglasses
since I was two years old these are
excellent sunglasses and by the way you
need to get good sunglasses you do it's
something especially during the summer
you wear them every day you change your
shirt every day you change your pants
every day you change but your sunglasses
you wear every day and you've got to
make sure that you look really good in
them that's most important and second of
all that they work really well and they
protect your eyes movements sunglasses
do both they are superb that's this is
one movement has sold 2.5 million
products across more than 160 countries
and their collections are always
expanding get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns go to MVM
t.com slash Knowles kano wles
see my movement keeps growing check out
their expanding collection MVM t.com /
noel scanner wles join the movement and
look good and be prepared for summer the
main takeaway from this Trump deal with
Mexico is that the chief purpose of the
negotiations were achieve
no matter what the mainstream media say
they were achieved big win for Trump but
for those of you who think that the
Trump is still an idiot I mean there are
some people I think who still think that
Donald Trump is just this incompetent
ignoramus
even though he somehow keeps achieving
all of his goals even if you think that
don't forget this deal was also achieved
with the negotiating skill of vice
president Pence and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo do you really think those
guys are just complete fools and
nincompoops idiots no this was there was
great skill involved in this deal there
was great brinksmanship there were great
threats of tariffs and it worked and
this is what's so important because when
this was announced on Friday everyone
basically had to admit that it worked
then people started to try to revise
history so the New York Times nothing in
post said it's not not really a big deal
it is a big deal and the the reason it's
a big deal is not even just for Mexico
and illegal immigration it's because of
what this says for China as we have been
engaged in a trade war with China for
and various proxy wars with China for
years and years now they steal our
intellectual property they violate World
Trade Organization treaties they
illegally subsidize their steel and
aluminum they inflate their currency
they they put spyware in our tech which
is all manufactured in China they are
quite hostile to us and so what
President Trump is doing is putting
pressure on them through trade to make
concessions to protect our IP all of
those goals of the United States and one
way he's doing it is threatening tariffs
what this is about this is a referendum
on the effectiveness of threatening
tariffs as a negotiating tool and what
we learned from the Mexico deal is it
works and what the left is desperately
trying to convince you is that no it
didn't really work don't believe your
lying eyes just believe what you read in
the New York Times it did work and this
is going to come back again and be very
important when we start talking about
China because those tensions aren't
going away anytime soon so enough about
geopolitics let's get to a genuinely
uplifting story that tells you a lot
about our culture it actually it tells
you a lot about our culture from the
spective of the story itself and from
the perspective of how people are
reacting to the story there's a
nine-year-old kid in California he
attends West Park Elementary School his
name is Ryan Kirkpatrick Ryan
Kirkpatrick realized that his classmates
had some school lunch debt so they would
show up to school and they their parents
didn't give them any money to buy lunch
at school and so the school still gives
them the lunch obviously but they're
just in debt so they had this debt and
this kid Ryan Kirkpatrick decided to pay
it off himself with his allowance money
his classmates had $74.50 in student
lunch debt
Ryan saved his money from his allowance
gave it to pay off the debt and and even
more importantly he did it anonymously
this story came out I guess because of
the either the parents are because of
the school but when Ryan himself did it
he did it anonymously and when when
asked finally why he did it he said
quote I want them just to realize people
actually think about them the classmates
instead of just telling them what they
did because you're just bragging about
stuff I want them to feel happy that
someone cares about them and this is the
key to the whole story because there is
a major ideological difference between
how people are reacting to this story
the people on the right heard this story
and they thought this is terrific this
is really beautiful it's uplifting it's
inspiring what a good kid what a kid who
is clearly raised right and who has just
made wonderful decisions the left saw
this story all you saw the blue
checkmarks on Twitter and you saw other
people reacting and saying that this is
awful
this is embarrassing for our country
terror depressing story because in a
country as rich as ours students
shouldn't have student lunch debt they
should the schools should provide all
the meals for the kids for free there
should be no dead this is so awful how
unjust it is how awful there were a lot
of people suggesting that schools should
just provide free lunches for all the
and breakfasts for all the
kids what our colleague matt walsh
pointed out the other day is if there
are 50 million kids in public school in
the united states you give them two
meals a day that's a hundred million
free meals per day they're 180 days in a
school year which means there are that
18 billion free meals per day that the
left wants us to create a new government
entitlement for that's what they're
calling for so that you say you could do
that or parents could stop being
deadbeats and feed their children new
federal entitlement 18 billion meals a
day or parents can be parents this story
overall is incredibly inspiring and the
reason it's inspiring is because a
nine-year-old kid decided to give his
allowance to charity anonymously that's
great that is just a morally wonderful
unqualified good act there is something
wrong in the story the thing that's
wrong is that deadbeat parents are not
feeding their children the thing that's
wrong in the story is not that the
government isn't doing enough our
government actually is doing enough the
schools are already providing the hot
lunches to the kids regardless of
whether or not they can pay so the
government is already doing that they're
already giving out the free lunches the
problem with this story is that deadbeat
parents aren't feeding their children if
you if you can't feed your children your
children should be taken from you it's
that simple
if you cannot feed your children either
a family member of yours who is not a
deadbeat should take your children and
raise them and take care of them or the
state should come in and remove your
children from you you deadbeat and give
them to a family that will not starve
them and will be able to give them basic
food feeding your children is the most
basic role of a parent there are many
things that parents do all parents most
basically have to feed their kids either
you can do it or a family member can do
it or the state can
now you say well what if some parents
don't make a lot of money then those
parents should go hungry while they feed
their kids well what if what what if
some parents I don't know they just
don't they don't have a good job they're
living in poverty first of all in
America that doesn't need to happen
because we have a robust social safety
net so if you aren't making a lot of
money I have friends and family who have
been in poverty and you can go on food
stamps or other welfare programs and
then you can use that to buy food and
feed your children what if that's not
enough or what if you're spending it
improperly or what if you don't qualify
or something there's a lot of private
charity also that will allow you to feed
your children the way to illustrate this
most clearly I think is that the poor in
America are much much much more likely
to suffer from obesity than they are
from starvation people don't starve in
America they don't starve by necessity
there are a lot of options in this
country the reason that these parents
are not feeding their children is not
because they don't have the money it's
not because life is so hard it's not
because they're starving it's because
they're stupid freakin deadbeats and
we're not holding them to account to do
their basic function as parents so in
this case obviously the schools should
give the kids food they shouldn't make
the kids go hungry but it's not just
that they should erase the student debt
or something the schools should give the
kids food and then call those parents
and hound them and ask them say hey
excuse me
this is principal so-and-so from the
school district why aren't you feeding
your child is something wrong do we need
to send Child Protective Services to
your house do we need to go have a
little intervention here why aren't you
feeding your kids now another takeaway
from this is that people can follow this
kids excellent example and give to
charity to make up for deadbeats I mean
that's what charity is for charity is a
wonderful thing everyone should give to
charity and it's great that this kid is
learning to give to charity
there's actually a word of caution here
because I know I was almost hesitant to
bring up this
story because I know what conservatives
are gonna think and really everybody in
this new internet culture we have is wow
this kid did such a good thing and now
we should reward that kid with a
GoFundMe campaign I bet one already
exists this is what we do now anytime
anyone does anything that we like
anytime anyone does any slight act of
kindness or act of charity we throw
hundreds of thousands of dollars at them
as though that's the only response there
should not be a GoFundMe for this do not
make a GoFundMe do not donate to a
GoFundMe people think that money solves
every problem money does solve a lot of
problems this isn't a problem this is
just charity this is a good thing an act
of charity is good and we should let
this kid engage in an act of charity and
see how it feels
and see how people react to it see what
it means and just do it it's a lovely
thing that's it that's all
so you got that's lovely good job kid
Ryan well done you're a you're an
inspiration to your classmates in your
countrymen speaking of child abuse we
have an example of really egregious
child abuse I guess even worse than not
giving your kid lunch we finally have to
address the case of the ten year old
drag queen that his parents are calling
him this is a truly horrifying story but
we have to address it because it's all
over the news right now
and it's I think better to confront it
head-on than to put our heads on the
stand any longer we've got that we've
got a lot more coming up we've got at
Kirsten Gillibrand making a fool of
herself we've got the poor masterpiece
cake shop guys getting targeted again
and another social media platform bans
conservatives but first I've got a
second bite of Facebook in YouTube go to
daily wire.com it's ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the Andrew Klavan show you got
the Ben Shapiro show you get them at
will show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get another Kingdom you
get the leftist ears tumblr why do you
need to subscribe to daily wire well you
get all that great stuff so that's
terrific the reason you need to
subscribe is because we are all about to
be kicked off of social media we're
going to be kicked off of YouTube we're
going to be kicked off of other social
media platforms
especially as the 2020 race heats up
it's just gonna happen there they've
launched this crusade it's been they
were testing the waters about six months
ago now they have gone full steam ahead
there D monetizing all conservatives
they're limiting the reach of my videos
on YouTube and we'll talk about that a
little bit more later it's just
happening so go subscribe right now if
you want to keep the content coming and
we'll be right back with a lot more
this story is horrifying but we just
have to talk about it there's a an 11
year old drag queen is not it's an 11
year old abused abused child whose
parents are calling him a drag queen his
stage name is Desmond is amazing I
didn't want to talk about this story
I've put off talking about it for months
or at least rather put off showing the
video I think I've mentioned it before
but I'm sure I put off showing the video
for months because I I just don't want
to add to this but it's everywhere it's
it's Pride Month this this kid is being
trotted out everywhere he's on all of
the media outlets online so I think it's
better to confront it head-on 11 year
old kid his name is Desmond
his parents are pimping him out as a
sexualized transvestite model and the
mainstream media are totally buying it
this from the Huffington Post I was born
in fragment in the year 2007 gay pride
means self-expression I'm a drag Kim and
I live in York City and I'm an LGBT
activist and advocate I discovered that
I wanted to dragony with the first
episode of RuPaul's Drag Race when I was
2 then I moved on to like little dresses
then I moved on to making outfits I have
got my right hand from designers like as
I'm the queen Betsey Johnson from Zig
our songs Jean Paul Gautier the club
kids their fashion and the makeup not
the bad things to blitz kids of London
if you want to do track to start off
with a little weight gain some lipgloss
and a little like t-shirt and a little
skirt and some heels or sneakers
whatever you can be addressing no matter
what I've always been able to be myself
because of my supporting mom and dad say
hi mom
that's my mom and I love her to death
drag is a form of expression and banging
ourselves and it
I think how everyone and looking fierce
so that is horrific IIIi don't know
where to begin he says that he got into
drag he knew he wanted to be a drag
queen when he was 2 years old and he's
able to do it because his parents are so
supportive say hi mom love her to death
yeah that's all true I guess it's the
parents parents who should be in prison
or deported they should not be permitted
anywhere near children or anywhere in
your polite society what they have done
should be a crime and they should go to
jail for that and they should be
arrested and not permitted in free
civilized society the parents are trying
to justify their abuse there's a profile
on them ironically in a website called
fatherly this is the headline Desmond is
amazing and the art of raising a child
drag queen Andrew Naples that's the
father jokes that his son was never in
the closet because there wasn't enough
room for his fabulousness
hah hah hah hah hah hah hah what a sick
pervert that father is what a sick
twisted pervert that guy is but you see
what he's trying to do even if he's
looking at this now and saying gosh this
is really messed up I've really made a
mistake even if he's looking at that
what he's trying to do is take his own
agency out of it he's saying oh oh we
knew we knew he was he was born this way
we knew he was born a drag queen no
one's born a drag queen you need
clothing and lipstick to be a drag queen
wasn't he wasn't born that way you made
him that way so no he just was he was he
was never in the closet because he was
just always so fabulous he right he goes
on he says I have a picture where I'm
holding him and he's the length of my
forearm he's like this big yeah he's
sitting there with a little smile on his
face posing for the camera five minutes
after he's born we should have known
right then but we didn't see he was so
the baby he was posing for the camera no
he wasn't
he's a newly born baby he's not even
conscious
babies aren't conscious for quite a
while after they're born he wasn't
posing for the cameras you imagined that
because you're a sick pervert and you're
trying to justify and rationalize the
horrific child abuse that you've
inflicted on your son he wasn't a drag
queen when he was born he wasn't
conscious and he wasn't naturally a drag
queen he says that he knew he wanted to
be a drag queen when he watched RuPaul's
Drag Race at age two first of all he
doesn't remember anything from when he
was aged two so that's a story that
you've told him that he's now been
convinced of but let's say he did
remember something from age 2 you showed
him a sexualized show about drag queens
when he was 2 because you were a pervert
and a horrible parent and you are
continuer right now currently abusing
your child the fatherly story goes on by
the time Desmond was 2 or 3 it was clear
to his parents that he was likely gay
they had been testing him what they've
been testing him exposing him to
different things what did he like the
[ __ ] duckling a 1999 animated film
about a duckling that doesn't quite fit
in
he named one of his two fish after him
RuPaul's Drag Race pride parades
musicals it wasn't that he was
indifferent to sports but that he saw
them as a distraction from fashion and
performance so Desmond really liked all
of the super confusing sexualized stuff
that you put in front of him when he was
3 that's what you're saying yeah we
experimented on we tested him is what
they said we put a lot of sexual content
in front of him and then he got confused
so therefore he was born a drag queen he
also - so they took him to pride parades
that's pretty weird but then they say at
the end there is say he really liked
musicals and he he didn't really care
for sports so therefore we knew he was
drag queen let me tell you here's a
confession time I liked a lot of
musicals as a kid I performed in
musicals
I saw a Broadway musicals and this is
gonna be a big shocker for you I wasn't
that good at sports I played Little
League for eight years I think I hit the
ball like four times but I leaned into
pitches so I had a very high
based percentage that's a story for
another time I was bad at sports I like
musicals I'm not a drag queen I'm not
gay I'm mostly a pretty regular guy
I wasn't posing for the cameras at at
five minutes after I was born because
nobody does because that's in your
pervert imagination because babies
aren't conscious when they're born all
of this evidence is just a way for these
parents to justify their abuse and you
know what they did these parents brought
this kid to a gay bar and they had him
dance on the bar while a bunch of men
threw dollar bills at him like he's a
stripper this is all cheered on in our
culture in the name of pride or gay
rights or LGBTQ am I allowed to say Q
anymore Q I think is now a bad word but
it's still in the acronym so I guess I
have to say it this is being cheered on
child abuse bringing a little
ten-year-old kid to a drag bar and
throwing dollar bills at him while you
talk about how sexy his dance moves are
our moral discourse on this issue has
become ridiculously shallow it's become
so shallow fortunately we have a
Democrat presidential candidate to sum
up with our entire moral discourse on
this question has become
[Music]
that's it it's just us wearing a shirt
kirsten gillibrand is wearing a rainbow
shirt at a gay bar on Pride Parade and
the shirt says love is brave which it's
not by the way love is wonderful love is
patient love is kind love is wonderful
we could talk for many years about what
love is it's not brave and she's there
and she's kind of dancing moving along
and then she just puts her hand up and
she yells at you goes gay rights gay
right that's it that's the whole thing
hey don't you think it's maybe a bad
idea to bring a ten-year-old boy to a
gay bar and have him dance on the bar
well lecherous men for a dollar bills at
him boom boom two gay rights oh I hadn't
considered that before what a what a
sophisticated response that makes me
think about this issue and in a new and
interesting way of course not let me ask
you this though let's say you're the
most extreme leftist sexual
revolutionary you say yeah absolutely we
should dress up our little children and
we should first of all when there to
show them sexualized television shows
about drag queens then we should dress
them up in sexualized ways then we
should take them to gay bars and have
Electress men for a dollar bills at them
let's say that you're all behind this
what if it were a little girl what if
there were a little girl who said I want
to be a pole dancer and oh yeah little
Suzy she knew she wanted to be a pole
dancer from age 2 we actually knew the
minute she was born she she you know she
was born we were swaddling her and then
she just jumped up and did a bunch of
spins on a pole and we knew she was a
pole dancer from the minute she was born
and she loved we showed her a bunch of
videos of strippers when she was two
years old and she really liked them so
we knew she was a stripper
from age two and so we brought a little
girl to a bar and she got up in
sexualized clothing and danced on a bar
well men threw dollar bills at her what
would we say about that would we say
that's gay gay rights pride great woohoo
yeah that's awesome what are we willing
to tolerate obviously the sexualization
of children is horrific and indefensible
the left tolerates it though
in the name of sexual liberation that's
what this is all about sexual liberation
you do you love is love be proud be
weird be proud how far are we willing to
go for sexual liberation are we willing
to abuse children the left is are we
willing to say no are we willing to stop
them are we willing to say no that
you've gone too far
forget about the sexualization of
children for a minute go to a completely
different place in this question of
sexual liberation right now the owner of
masterpiece cake shop Jack Phillips
we've had him on the show before Jack
Phillips is now being sued again for a
third time for refusing to participate
in activities that violate his religious
beliefs he first became prominent
because these LGBTQ activists targeted
Jack Phillips to try to get him to bake
a cake a customized cake for a gay
wedding so-called and he said I can't do
that because I'm an Orthodox Christian
and I don't think there's any such thing
as a gay wedding and it violates my
religious beliefs to use my artistic
skills to create a custom cake to be
part of your gay wedding if you want to
just buy one of my regular cakes you're
more than welcome to buy one of those
and then you can use it at your wedding
but they didn't actually want the cake
they wanted to ruin his life because
Jack Phillips is a Christian so they
said no you have to make a custom cake
and if you don't we're gonna sue you
into the ground and take away your
livelihood and your business so they did
that the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission came out against him they
tried to litigate this guy into the dirt
this one all the way up to the Supreme
Court and he won so guess what they did
they went after him again
a transgender activist a fella by the
name of the autumns Gardena then it
tried to get him to bake a cake to get
Phillips to bake a cake to celebrate his
score Dena's gender change I don't know
what they call the transformation and he
wanted the cake to be blue on the
outside and pink on the inside
get it because he's a man on the outside
but he's a woman on the inside frankly
I'm very offended that this guy autumns
Gardena would associate blue with
masculinity and pink with femininity how
bigoted how judgmental how patriarchal
you don't boys don't get blue girls
don't get pink how dare you sir that's
again a side note Jack Phillips refused
to bake the cake so they follow this
case all the way down Phillips does okay
now there is a third lawsuit again by
this trans activist autumns Gardena and
it's not for refusing to bake a gay
wedding cake it's not for refusing to
bake a trans celebration cake it's for
refusing to bake a birthday cake
ah so this transgender activist now now
he's got Phillips the trick here you
might wonder why didn't Phillips just
bake the birthday cake it's because it's
a birthday cake for Satan
this guy autumns Gardena once Phillips
to bake a cake that would feature an
upside-down cross in black and red
frosting and a head of Lucifer so as you
might imagine Jack Phillips declined
this this began by the way the day that
the Supreme Court ruled in favor of Jack
Phillips this activist called him and
asked for another cake a three-tiered
white cake cheesecake frosting the
topper would be a large figure of Satan
licking a 9-inch black sex toy use your
imagination and the sex toy had to be a
working model according to the request
so this obviously it's nothing to do
with the cake there are a lot of
bakeries around here by the way you
think Jack Phillips is the only Baker in
America they're actually explicitly
LGBTQ bakeries the LGBTQ centered
bakeries closer to the people asking for
these cakes than Phillips but they
target Phillips because they want to
ruin his life
because he's a Christian I've met this
guy you might think because he's been in
the news so much this guy Jack Phillips
he's probably not a regular Baker he's
probably some kind of activist he's just
look they're trying to get famous on it
he's trying to get famous on it it's
just a political battle not so he's
actually just a nice Baker he's just a
nice guy I've met him I was
actually shocked as though you actually
are a baker who is just completely being
unfairly targeted for being a Christian
this shows you that the calls for
live-and-let-live tolerance you do you
all of that is nonsense this shows you
that the left they're not happy with
tolerance they're not happy with
acceptance they're not happy with
toleration they want to break down your
beliefs you now no longer are permitted
to hold Orthodox Christian Jewish or
Islamic views on sexuality on YouTube
that's not allowed anymore that's hate
speech that's gone you're now not
allowed to refuse to bake a cake for
Satan's birthday that's gone they want
to destroy your religious belief so you
know we've been talking about this this
debate that's been going on on the right
do we want a conservatism that begins
with certain religious premises certain
cultural premises like so Rob Amari the
writer was advocating a traditional
conservatism or do we want this kind of
classical liberalism that says there's
no foundation to anything it's just all
a neutral space there's no neutral space
there's not this is what neutral space
gets you it gets you it gets your life
ruined and your business destroyed
because you refused to bake a sects
birthday cake for Satan that's what it
comes down to a little news we have to
get to before we get out of here
Pinterest is a new social media platform
banning conservatives it's not a new
social media platform it's been around
for a while we have now uncovered we now
know they are banning conservatives and
that's thanks to James O'Keefe at
project Veritas Pinterest is now
blocking for sure ben shapiro our editor
in chief so i got to assume they're
blocking all of the daily wire content
they're blocking pj media a right-wing
site they're blocking live action
they're now saying live action is
pornography that's the pro-life site and
this is all thanks to James O'Keefe
talking to a big tech whistleblower who
showed him the slack threads the email
threads showed him behind the curtain
that live action is going after
conservatives here's just a little bit
of that interview what are we looking at
here it seems to be a
a bunch of xxx and porn websites and
then and then there appears to be the
live-action website what what are we
looking at here looking at pins with
domains that are blocked any domain on
the porn block list you can't make a pin
like that and I happen to discover this
because of a slack thread are talking
about pro-life content and somebody
happening noticed that live action that
was blocked and so I was pretty
surprised and I went to our own domain
walk west and live-action is a group
founded by Lila Rose that tries to
educate people about the pro-life
movement
- Garwood was added to a pion walk west
that means that if you try to make a pin
that links to live action org you won't
be able allowed to then will be created
making with some trusting safety team
and on government operations and she was
the one who added live action god word
to the poor domain walk west so we're
getting a lot of good information the
reason that that guy's voice is all
messed up it's not because it's James
Earl Jones as the whistleblower it's
because he he wants to keep his identity
anonymous obviously this is absurd to
add a lot live action is the most
wholesome website on the Internet it's
literally just exists to protect babies
and stop babies from being killed it is
the most wholesome family-friendly
website on the entire internet you know
if they had added daily wire as a porn
website
I mean I've taken some strange photos
here I mean I've taken photos without
any pants on a on a couch I've taken
photos licking a cake without a shirt on
so I would understand that a little bit
more live action there's no explanation
other than this was a vindictive play
from a social media platform abusing its
power abusing the rights these special
protections that have been given to it
by the government and it is using that
because it really supports abortion and
it wants to shut up pro-life activists
because they know they can't win the
argument so they have to censor them now
it's not just live action that's being
targeted here it's not just the narrow
case of abortion
it's it's Christians generally it's it's
so much more of the people who reject
leftist orthodoxy areas fix it turns
porn terms anything that we don't want
to show up on search there are a lot of
times about cushions or devotions so we
have Pinterest open right now
I'm going to type in the word Muslim and
what we see happen on the screen is it
separates it into two words Muslim
fashion Muslim quotes and this is called
autocomplete I'll do it again for the
for the word Jewish
I'll type into search Jewish our Jewish
wedding Jewish recipe but then I type in
the word Christian and something
interesting happens questions we work
from autumn complete some of the other
words that are on this severity level is
sandwich cocaine one-night stand Paris
attack and quote [ __ ] unquote and
those are now being compared to
questions
so in autocomplete now you can search
Jewish Muslim but when you search
Christian this is this is being blocked
and it's being put on the level of
cocaine and racial slurs and pornography
sex searches Christianity specifically
singled out not not religion generally
not religious freedom Christianity
anti-christian anti baby anti pro-life
anti conservative that's what we're
getting
according to the documents James O'Keefe
found been was censored in a quote zero
tolerance movement Christianity blocked
from autocomplete video series exposing
Planned Parenthood was in a sensor list
as a harmful conspiracy a harmful
conspiracy that we can watch on video
don't believe your lying eyes just
believe Pinterest live action on a list
of porn sites content couldn't be
clicked through by users the the slack
channels this is my favorite part the
slack channels on the public policy and
social impact managers instructed
employees to quote monitor the platform
for white supremacist content from
individuals like conservative
commentators ben shapiro and candice
Owens
white supremacists content by a Jew and
a black girl that's the sneakiest white
supremacists those are the ones you
forget the regular white white
supremacist the ones you got to look at
for the Jewish and black ones this is
just another platform how many other
social media platforms are doing this
how much more intense is this social
media censorship going to get before
2020 and what needs to happen before
conservatives come to their senses and
start insisting that the law be enforced
on these companies to break up their
outrageous abuses of power all good
questions we'll get to them some other
time I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 hey everyone its Andrew clave
and host of the Andrew Clavin show faked
hearings in Washington amplified by fake
news on the networks immortalized and
fake movies in the theaters and on TV
the left has created an empire of lies
in which America is living under racist
and sexist depression led by that
reincarnated Hitler Donald Trump I'll
take you into the heart of the Machine
plus I've got an interview with a true
American hero on the Andrew Klavan show
Andrew Clavin